you may say and think that you're not a
sexist or racist but that is only more
proof an ever building pile of proof of
the double secret precious micro
aggressing ways in today's installment
of social justice warrior dictionary
we're going to be learning about
microaggressions Todd is a legitimate
theory at universities and tumblers
across the country you'd think that
everybody in Maine's for America would
know exactly what micro aggression means
only when we asked people have you heard
of the term micro aggression what's that
when you think about it no no I do not
know the term micro no sir you haven't
no I haven't surprised only one person
knew what micro aggression actually
meant a white woman studies feminists
have you heard the term micro aggression
yes so in order to clear up any micro
aggressing confusion we dug up this old
instructional video you can thank us
later
rise and shine Bobby hey there Bobby
today we're going to talk about
microaggressions mr. Oh Bobby your white
privilege is showing what see Bobby
microaggression is a social justice
warrior term referring to commonplace
daily verbal behavioral or environmental
indignities whether intentional or
unintentional that communicate hostile
derogatory or negative racial slights or
insults towards any minority classes Oh
Bobby
you've so much to learn you who don't
have to be you could be a sexist -
homophobic lacist or even a trans folk
but you're probably a racist
- you just don't know it yet that's the
beauty of micro aggression I'm so glad
you've asked Bobby the land of
microaggressions can be confusing to the
uninformed here are a few simple
questions to ask yourself hey do you
have a penis B is it white C are you not
not ashamed of your white penis
congratulations your micro Bobby that
sounds like you're trying to be
colorblock there's your microaggressions
showing again according to the neuro
scientists at BuzzFeed attempting to
judge people autonomously from their
racial or sexual identity is just as
discriminatory as judging them based on
their racial or sexual identity the
beauty of micro aggression Theory Bobby
you can everybody is a racist sexist
prejudiced micro aggressor even if they
don't realize it and there's no proof at
all
so no proof at all this actually even
more proof that I'm an insensitive
microbe pressing bag of human oh now
you're getting it Bobby well sounds like
bingo that's the goal of microaggression
theory just remain silent bend over and
take it Annie I hope you've learned
something here today I know I have which
is really hard because I can't read and
that's why I'm so glad that audible is
partnering up with louder with Crowder
audible is really just the biggest and
best audio book library you can find
anywhere on the web and this week if you
go to audible.com slash Crowder you can
pick out a free book of your choosing
that's audible.com slash Crowder and
then you can get the app going the whole
shebang it's incredibly convenient it's
really easy listening I know people talk
about things that they like but the
truth is with the radio show the podcast
we have a lot of guests who come on and
they want to talk about their book I
don't have enough time in the day to
read everybody's book but with audible I
can be doing my work I can be writing an
article I can be editing a video and
still listen to the audiobook in the
background and sometimes it's really
cool to hear the author narrate their
own book which is why I recommend Andrew
Clavin friend of the show his book
werewolf cop because his voice is
literally like buttered chocolate sex
cowboy and Broadway Joe doesn't get much
better than that seriously though super
grateful that audible is a fan of the
show they've supported us I hope you
support them it's genuinely a good and
convenient product again try it for free
this week go to audible.com slash
Crowder and I really don't think you'll
be disappointed because it's free you
get to try it but this being YouTube I'm
sure some of you will complain anyway
this micro aggressive scum
there's a new take over and it's not
stashed